c'est une reprise en douceur pour le
club de plongée de hier en compagnie de
six clients tous des habitués
après un confinement très contraignant
ces plongeurs ne boudent pas leur
plaisir au moment d'enfiler leur
combinaison de nouveau alors que
d'ordinaire la saison de plongée démarre
vers la fin mars
c'est avec deux mois de retard que les
clubs reprennent leurs activités
non sans avoir pris soin d'appliquer les
consignes sanitaires imposées par les
autorités et la fédération française
d'études et de sports sous-marins
vous verrez que sur le bateau il y avait
à voir des emplacements signalés par du
scotch parlera par des bandes orange
donc qui sont à plus d'un mètre l'un de
l'autre comme ça ça vous donne à sept
places et des espaces
en plus de ces aménagements un protocole
sanitaires très strictes a été mis en
place avant toute sortie en mer chaque
plongeur de se soumettre à un
questionnaire visant à déterminer son
exposition covit 19
ces deux derniers mois un passage
impératif car le coronavirus peut aller
porter gravement atteinte au poumon et
au coeur deux organes qui doivent être
en parfait état pour pratiquer la
plongée sous marine pour qu'on soit
certain que chaque personne qui pratique
la plongée soit en pleine capacité
physique avant de avant de plonger on
peut pas on peut pas aller plonger à 20
ou 30 ou 40 mètres en ayant eu des
petits problèmes
direction l'île de port cros un parc
mondialement connu pour ses mérous et
dont les eaux sont peu profondes dont
idéal pour reprendre l'activité sur
l'embarcation une distance d'un mètre
entre chaque plongeur doit être
respectée et le port du masque anti
qu'ovide 19 est obligatoire une fois
dans l'eau c'est un autre masque dont
les plongeurs ont besoin et ils ne
boudent pas leur plaisir
pour leur première sortie en mer depuis
octobre
si tous se réjouissent d'un retour
progressif à la normale le manque à
gagner demeure énorme pour les clubs de
plongée qui doivent revoir à la baisse
le nombre de clients sur les bateaux par
exemple un bateau qui est homo
l'homologuer comme celui ci il est
homologué officiellement 22
même deux plongeurs là du coup on est
limité à 10 donc en moins de la moitié
bien évidemment les les coûts les
charges restent les mêmes
une fois rentré le nettoyage du bateau
est obligatoire et se fait avec un
produits bactéricides ou virucide
combinaison gillet détenteurs l'ensemble
du matériel est plongé dans un bac d'eau
enrichi avec du désinfectant un
protocole contraignant auquel vont
devoir se plier les quelques 2000 club
de plongée en france il en va de la
sécurité des trois cent mille plongeurs
que compte le pays